in the game of Thrones books lots of
characters have secret identities like
Sansa pretends to be Elaine Varys
pretends to be rügen may not plum is
actually Bloodraven who's also the
three-eyed crow Robert strong is the
mountain Griff is John Kahn young Griff
is Aegon Targaryen who might actually be
a Blackfyre the list goes on and on and
one of the coolest of these sacred
identities is aller s aller ass is a
student at the Citadel in Old Town which
is like the Westerosi University he's
involved with Sam Tarly
Marwin the mage and Jack and Hegar who
seek secrets in the Citadel al-harazi
minor character but he's got a secret of
his own cuz he is actually a she
she's sir Ellis and a bastard daughter
of Oberyn Martell the most obvious
evidence that a la raza relah
is that the name alas is Sorella
backwards but also we know that sir
Ella's father is Oberyn Martell of Dorne
and sir Ella's mother is a trader from
the Summer Isles aler ass is the same
his mother is a trader from the Summer
Isles and his father is a Dornishmen ala
receivin looks like Oberyn they both
have black eyes and black hair with a
widow's peak at one point Alaris says I
am no Lord's son which is true cuz she's
actually a Lords daughter Alerus is
always smiling as if he knows some
secret jape and the evidence shows that
his secret is that she is actually sir
Ellis and so who is sarella in the show
Oberyn Martell has three daughters but
in the books he has eight called the
sand snakes
serella is the fourth born now 19 years
old in book four the three eldest sand
snakes
Obara Nymeria and tyene want to start a
war with the Lannisters to avenge the
deaths of Oberyn and aren't Elia to
prevent this war their uncle Doran
arrests the snakes Oberyn MTN and the
young ones are captured but Duran
doesn't arrest
serella because Sorella isn't in Dorne
she's in Old Town as a laroz Duran says
unless she returns to dawn there's not I
can do about Sorella the
her to her game so it doesn't sound like
Sirella is working with Duran or with
the other sand snakes
what is her game what's she doing in old
town serella loves learning on a visit
to some ruins
serella turned over rocks brush sand of
mosaics and wanted to know everything
there was to know about the people who
had lived there so maybe serella
came to the Citadel University because
she wants to learn stuff her father
Oberyn did the same thing but the
Citadel doesn't accept women which must
be wise Sorella disguises herself as a
guy Alerus and allure a Stas well at the
Citadel earning three links of his
maesters chain in one year meaning she
masters three subjects really fast and
she seems to care about the values of
the Citadel telling lazy Leo that he
shames the Citadel by being one of them
also
Nymeria mentions that Sirella loves the
city of old town so Sorella is smart she
wants to learn and she loves the Citadel
and old town and that's probably why
she's there but Sirella / Alerus /
Zarrella wrasse gets involved in much
more than just study at the start of
book 4 Alerus practices archery with his
golden heart bow which connects to his
sama island a heritage he talks with his
student friends about the rumors of the
Dragon Queen Daenerys in the east and
this guy Leo reveals that there's a
glass candle burning in the chambers of
Marwan the mage a glass candle is a
candle of obsidian and for centuries
these candles have been impossible to
light but now they burn again which
shows that magic and Dragons have
returned to the world old powers waken
Leah says shadows stir and Alerus is
really interested in this talk of magic
and Dragons so by the end of the book he
becomes an ally of the guy with the
candle Marwan Marwan is a rebel
professor he travels to strange distant
places studies with strange people like
Qyburn and mary mazda and he writes
books about prophecy he's an expert on
magic but most maesters don't trust
magic so they discredit Marwan Marwan
claims there's a conspiracy by the
maesters to suppress magic and Dragons
what
this video for more so marwan's a little
crazy maybe but he totally knows things
about magic and prophecy partly because
he has this glass candle because glass
candles let you see across distances and
enter dreams
Marwin uses his to watch and learn he
sees Sam arrive at the Citadel
so Marwan gets a Lara's to bring Sam to
him and Sam tells them about his
experiences at the wall with White
Walkers and Melisandre and how maester
aemon thinks Daenerys is azor Ahai the
hero prophesied to save the world
so Marwan leaves and heads east to meet
Daenerys
this leaves Sam at the Citadel with al
arrest and with a guy called paté who is
actually the faceless assassin Jack and
Hagar in disguise jaqen is there
possibly to steal a book called the
death of dragons go watch the jaqen
video but also Sam has an old horn which
is probably the Horn of winter which can
destroy the wall also also there are
Ironborn raiding around old town and
year on Greyjoy's making an eldritch
mass blood sacrifice nearby so there's a
lot of intense magic [ __ ] converging on
Old Town and Alerus seems connected our
asses friends call him the Sphinx
because a sphinx has the face of a human
body of a lion and wings of a hawk it's
made up of different parts just like
Allah wrasse is both Dornish and summer
Islander but the Sphinx might also refer
to a LaRosa's secret identity there are
statues of sphinxes at the Citadel one
male and one female
which might hint at Sorella wrasses male
and female identities but the sphinx
symbol goes even deeper because on the
way to old town maester aemon tell Sam
that the Sphinx is the riddle not the
Riddler Sam wonders if alas the Sphinx
is the Sphinx a maan meant maybe the
idea is that allah wrath is not a
Riddler who'll tell you a riddle ala ass
is the riddle as in his secret identity
as Sorella is the riddle but why would a
maan talk about the secret identity of
some minor character he's never met a
mon mentions the Sphinx along with talk
of dreams glass candles a
and the three heads of the Dragon which
seems to be the idea that three Dragon
Riders will write Danny's three dragons
Alerus also mentions the three heads of
the Dragon and he is involved with glass
candles so maybe a la raza to this tug
Aryan dragon stuff in book five Tyrion
finds of Valyrian Sphinx a dragon queen
with the head of a woman and body of a
dragon she seems to be missing her King
a male half human half dragon if the
female dragon Sphinx is Daenerys the
male could be Jon Snow he's part dragon
because he's half Targaryen and he's
probably the rightful king of Westeros
and he could be Danny's future husband
and he could be one of the three heads
who rides a dragon Jon might be the
Sphinx a Mon ment and this could link
back to LRS if Alaris and sam uncovered
Jon's true parentage of the Citadel like
Sam and Gilly do in the show so the
riddle of the Sphinx is still vague and
confusing but it seems to connect John
and Danny and the Targaryen dragons with
Sorella wrath what does this mean for
her future
it looks like LRS will be Sam study
buddy at the Citadel they might learn
important secrets about White Walkers or
a Zora hi or John's parentage but with
Jack and Hagar around they might also
get caught up in his plot to steal that
dragon book Marwin and al-araf seem to
want to support Daenerys but Allah asks
could also become Danny's enemy because
in book five Dany rejects a marriage
alliance with Dawn and one of Danny's
dragons kills sir Ella's cousin Quentin
so maybe Sorella ass will use her
archery skills to slay a dragon Jack uns
book the death of Dragons might help at
the same time Euron brings sorcery and
destruction on Old Town we'll Sorella
fight to protect the city she loves so
like a sphinx Sorella ass is made of
different parts
she's a sand snake daughter of Oberyn
Martell of Dorne but she's also a summer
Islander with a golden heart bow she's a
student of the Citadel with a love for
Old Town and ties to Marwan and she also
seems connected to the Targaryen
Danny this complex combination of
conflicting loves and loyalties define
the Sphinx as one of the most
interesting minor characters in the
series thank you to the artists who
kindly made illustrations for this video
check out drafter G and Mandy Fink among
others linked below thanks for watching
and thanks to the patrons including
Horia bogged down Maximilian shoot Jam
Samantha Morris and poop King Cheers
you